thank you for joining me on et Canada
pride thanks for having me this is super
fun before we started shooting we were
just talking about how much you love
Canada I absolutely love Canada I don't
wanna leave I'm thinking about like
moving here please have me I wouldn't
mind leaving America for just a little
bit just to like you know check out
things from the other side you know yeah
I mean things are good here right now
good things are good you're shooting
season two of what we do in the shadows
here yeah
tell me a bit about season two because
this show has such a huge fan base and
people are anticipating it I'm so
excited for everyone to see where the
storylines go as if you saw seizing one
you know that we left off with the bun
housing you know cliffhanger and so we
dive into that a little bit more and
where that goes and so many guest stars
are coming you guys are gonna like
especially uh if you like musical
theater there's some couple cameos that
you're gonna like die so you can you
drop a name I mean it's like I could say
like good morning Baltimore or welcome
to the 60s or like whoa oh oh whoa cup
to day feeling the way I all that I
can't say too much so speaking about the
fan base of the show I mean like I said
it has it has such a great fan base that
have just fallen in love with the series
as an actor on it you never know if the
show is gonna hit you never know if it's
gonna find an audience why do you think
the show has found such an audience
I think it's that it's so absurd the
idea that vampires would live amongst us
but it's so grounded in reality that I
think people love that I would like some
of that a colorful dust that sparkles
glitter I'm going to sprinkle it on my
face and on my body
like my life it's like the office you
know real people everyday but it happens
to be vampires and I think that's so
funny I think that the idea that you if
you take something so seriously and it's
your everyday life that's what the humor
comes so unsaid just being grounded and
being present that's where most of the
jokes come from something else I love
about the series is that sexuality is
not like a taboo topic I love that I
love that all the vampires have slept
with men women everyone orgy everything
it's not even part of the dialogue it's
just of what they're made of it's just
who they are and it's so accepted so
it's we never make it a focus of just
saying who the vampires they slept with
both men and women it's a it's just
something that they talk about as very
matter-of-fact and it's never something
that you're stopping and saying wait a
minute are you and necessarily giving a
label to it's it's like they're just
vampires who enjoy sex whatever you
would you know and it's like so they're
very LGBTQ friendly and they're very
part of the queer family for some reason
I feel like like me growing up I
gravitated towards darker things I don't
know if that's because I'm a member of
the lgbtq+ community but like vampires
or witches or stuff like that Buffy the
Vampire Slayer like I was always
gravitated towards that and I feel like
a lot of members of the community do why
do you think that is I think it's
because for so long we've been outcasts
and so for so long we've been put into
our own category in the corner and to be
you know may be seen but not heard or
even neither or and for so long we felt
like you know we were on the outside
looking in and so characters like
vampires brought us into like this
spotlight where even though you're
different you're accepted and you can be
loved and you can't be approachable and
you are charming and you are leading
like those things were not available
even when I look at Hollywood like you
know not so long ago you couldn't be a
lead on a show if you're openly gay or
openly queer and those things have
changed slowly but surely but we're
getting there so I think we've always
been drawn to that because that's our
community we've always been the underdog
and here we are and you know you guys
have your own like et kept on like I'm
like so excited to be here as an actor
who's queer and who's Mexican
did you find it difficult trying to
break through that Hollywood barrier
yeah I always you know looking back I
remember having professors who would
tell me things that were supposed to be
encouraging like hey are you going to
lose the weight or hey are you going to
be open about who you are and I never
thought of that as being anything to do
with my craft you know it's Who I am as
a person who I am as a person is my
thing you know and so for me represent a
character as something to do with my
personal life so for so long I remember
just being told he'll never be the comic
relief you know who's the leading guy
because you're to this or to Mexican or
you're too big though you're to query
too it's like I decided that I was
trying to fit a mold but I got tired of
it because when you walk down the beach
you don't stop for the rock that looks
like all the other rocks you stop for
the rock that looks different so I
started focusing on made me unique and
that's when things change yeah it's
funny it's almost like when we accept
ourselves in a certain except I say that
you know that's when things really
happen and everyone jumps on board you
know when someone says I love myself you
know a great example is like Liz oh you
know what I mean it's like coming so
talented and beautiful and when she
presents that that's what she's
presenting people like you know what she
is talented she is beautiful and her
like a background her size it doesn't
come to play because that she's just
that person she is this beautiful human
being I feel like our trans brothers and
sisters haven't always been represented
in media but I feel like that's getting
better you know the series like pose
like fantast
another FX show another effect you know
which they no other network you know I
spoke with speaking as the creator of
pose and he was telling me that he
pitched that show for like 10 years you
know and networks were in willing to
take a risk like they just were it was
too ahead of its time with that world
and FX did and so I got a you know give
props to FX who always take risk and
their shows when you look at their
lineup of shows they've always put out
work that mix it's controversial it's
you know a topic of conversation like
it's so great to just have the
opportunity to work for a network of
that yeah and there comes a point to I
think in everyone's career where maybe
things aren't going the way we want them
to
was there ever a point where you almost
just gave up on that dream or were you
always pushing through I think that
always pushed through I think there was
a moment
society was telling me give up it's a
girl give it up yeah and I was just like
no you know because I remembered the
first time I fell in love with acting
was when I was 6 years old
and I I was watching the movie Annie and
I felt the TV sure because I was playing
on TV and I asked my mom that I wanted
to be that you know I told her mom I
want to be that I want to be an orphan
and she looked at me weird
she said no they're actors and I like oh
I wanna be an actor and I didn't have
money
single mom low income family Mexican you
know immigrants didn't have the money so
I had to collect cans out of trash cans
like aluminum bottles and like cans like
sell those the recycling bins and paid
for my first improv class and I was 6
years old so I worked really hard to get
where I'm at and so I didn't come this
far just to come this far what do you
want to see more of in media is there a
more queer representation you would love
to see I would love to see more queer
characters just living their lives and
not necessarily making it just the story
of them you know queer it's just like
living the comic relief the lead comic
relief finding a love interest you know
we're just getting to the point where
we're having our first you know comedy
with a love interest and whatnot and so
those things are slowly changing that I
love see more of that where people have
the choice to go and like you know oh
you may not be part of that world but
you can tap into it and come and say hey
what's going on in there it's like oh I
never knew we bet you guys live like
this again we're just like you and so
then you see the difference where it's
like there is no division really you
know it's just that we live our everyday
life and so then make clear actors leads
and shows make them queer you know
everything I think we're getting there
well even Jordan I think we are too
you've worked on some amazing projects
over here time I mean you're on the good
place you've started films with some
Hollywood stars as anybody offered you
any advice about the industry that
you've kind of held on to
I'm trying to think I think working on
the internship with Rose Byrne she was
so lovely and so humble and after she
had like an amazing you know at that
point and still does career and to be so
sweet and giving and I told her any
advice like or have you changed anything
like no just remember what who you were
when you came in and if you just stay
with that everything will just be peachy
keen you know because you don't change
who you are because it's who you are
that's make me better than that yeah
what advice now that you're on a hit
television show what advice would you
give to the lgbtq+ community is there
something you would tell them whether if
it's about chasing their dreams or just
self-acceptance what message would you
send to them I would say keep doing you
like it's literally if you want to get
into entertainment industry don't let
anyone stop you don't let anyone tell
you that you're not good enough just
keep doing you and be a representation
of the community just be yourself and
make us proud I love that thank you for
chatting with super fun